john is with us john is in san diego hi
john how are you
hi how's it going dave and john it's
pleasure to talk with you guys
you too what's up um
so my mother is getting a
what would you call it a um a gift from
my grandmother selling her
house and she's about to receive
probably around 150 000
and she wants to use that to buy a house
here
and basically the problem is
my father is kind of hesitant because
he's been burned in the past
um we lost her house back in the 08
crisis
and he's just afraid of like basically
something happening in the future and
not being able to uh
hold on to the house basically that's
understandable
so what's the question so i so um
he actually wants me to co-sign with him
because my mother is actually getting
back to work
um he feels that his credit isn't
up to up to a certain amount that would
get him the loan
even with the 20 percent yeah no
yeah no way no you don't co-sign for
anyone ever
think about what you just asked you
asked
my dad is so scared that something bad's
gonna happen again
that this time he wants to attach me to
it
right yeah because that's why i wasn't
sure about doing that yeah
no you're super sure you know it's just
hard when your dad says hey man i'm so
scared that i'm gonna drown i want to
chain myself to you so if i drown you
john too how about that
and i know that's not what he's saying
at all but it is actually what he's
saying that's what he's done
that's what he's gonna do yeah it's not
what he meant so the answer is no
yeah it is not good for him and it's not
good for you to co-sign
if they are not in a position to buy a
home they need to do the things they
need to do to get in a position to buy a
home now
we can alleviate your dad's fears
of buying a home and something bad
happening you're not going to lose your
home
[Music]
your own it's very rare for you to lose
your home if you have an emergency fund
of three to six months of expenses
and you have no other debt but the home
and you buy a home where the payments no
more than a fourth of your take-home pay
on a 15-year fixed rate
now those are ramsey guidelines on
buying a home and if he does all of that
which i suspect since his credit sucks
that he has debt and he has some
outstanding bad debt doesn't he
actually he's getting out of baby step
two i think he only owes about three
thousand dollars on his car
okay then he had some old bad done okay
he did yeah he had some back
back taxes and yeah other debt is that
and that's all paid now
yes that's good that's great well let's
get through six months of expenses built
up or hold that back out of the 150
one of the two and it's okay if he sits
there and rents for uh six months to a
year with absolutely zero debt except
that rental
his credit will start to heal
but i would never i never tell anyone to
co-sign
i i have co-signed for people and had
the opportunity to pay the bill the
reason
a bank wants a cosigner is because they
don't think the main signer is going to
pay
it's always a signal to me when a when a
business
that tells me loaning money i won't take
your money yeah
right i love loaning money but not to
this guy without your help
right so that instead of it being an
insult it should be a signal right
there you go that's it and and it's
you're not being disloyal to your dad
as a matter of fact quite the contrary
you're being loyal to him because here's
what's going to happen
you're going to move on with your last
five or six years they're going to move
on everything's going to be okay
you're on the stinking loan and you
decide it's time to buy a house because
you got married or you and your wife
currently go decide to buy a house
and guess what you can't because you
have this contingent liability called a
co-signature on his
it's going to bring you down keep you
from buying a house or every time he
pays late you know what it does it dings
your credit
or he gets sick and can't work and
suddenly you are having to work to pay
his
house payment because it's your house
payment because you
signed for it too proverbs 13 or is not
proverbs 13
17 proverbs 17 18 says
one lacking incense cosigns for another
that's the new king james version if you
read the contemporary english version it
says
it is stupid to cosign it's exactly what
it says
i thought that was the dave ramsey no
it's a contemporary english version it's
a real version of the bible
says it's stupid to cosign yeah
because of the whole the whole premise
is you're going to end up paying it
i don't know i don't know a family that
doesn't have
some sort of discord in it because
somebody signed for a student loan
somebody
borrowed money from their borrow money
from grandpa whatever i mean this is
this this in this incestuous handling of
money
is uh it's it's just a disaster please
don't do it john i know you're i know
i know you want to do good by your dad
but just smile
be kind be loving say dad i love you i
love you and i want good things for you
i'm and and me being on this loan is not
a good thing for you or
me um i'm going to be your biggest
cheerleader
i'm so proud of what you've done getting
these debts paid off and being on baby
step 2
him but don't co-sign for him
and parents that would agree that would
be the same thing for your children kids
in the that sense
but the opposite is don't co-sign for
your kids to get a house no
you know i'm trying to help my baby in
your house yeah
leave your grown children to be grown
yes
it's an it's a novel idea a helicopter
and so so have you have heard this term
i'm speaking uh coleman and i were
talking about this
yesterday i guess i've got a friend that
works
um in uh educating the education field
coaching
uh school administrators and and um
uh teachers and so on and she said you
were at dinner she was telling she said
you know there's all these new terms now
and she said you know the helicopter
parent is oh yeah i know
i definitely know what helicopter they'd
fly in you know pick up you know take
care of everything
yeah she said do you know what a
lawnmower parent is do you no i do not
i've not heard that what is that
not it's a true thing though huh what is
it they cut the grass out in front of
them
uh so that they don't have any hard
times assuring that they will never know
how to handle
hard times not if assuring they never
know how to walk through tall grass
wow no i've never heard that before
that's lawnmower parents
lawnmower parents are the next step
after you're a helicopter parent and
it's continuing to deteriorate
so the great the greatest these are all
these great phrases for codependent
the greatest the parenting thing was my
wife i went to help
hank i know him to fall down and she
said he's gonna fall down
once and that was the greatest like let
him fall
then he won't climb back up on that
anymore oh she's so wise
tough